Willkommen an der Österreichischen
Militärakademie. Ich bin Carl Marcos Risner. Ich bin
Leiter der Abteilung für Forschung und
Entwicklung und derzeit
Kommandeur der Ehrengarde in Wien.
Heute schauen wir uns den
sogenannten Ukrainischen an  Sommeroffensive und
wie der aktuelle Stand eigentlich ist.
Wir haben ein paar Monate mit der
Erstellung dieses Videos gewartet, weil wir
ein Endergebnis haben wollten
und nach 195 Tagen können wir tatsächlich
schon eine erste Einschätzung
zur Offensive haben  Bevor wir mit
einem tiefen Einblick in die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive beginnen, möchten wir Ihnen zwei
Folien aus unserem letzten Briefing Anfang
Juni zeigen. Die Idee war, in diesen
Folien zu zeigen, welche Erwartungen
damals an die ukrainische Gegenoffensive geknüpft waren  Wir gingen davon aus, dass es
eine Art letzten
und entscheidenden Angriff in Richtung Süden geben wird,
um das von Russland besetzte
Gebiet in zwei Abschnitte zu teilen, einen im
Südwesten und einen im
Nordosten, verbunden mit einem weiteren
Angriff auf die Brücke  Über die
Straße von K hinaus bestand der strategische Effekt darin,
durch die Isolierung der
Russen im Südwesten die Russen
an den
Verhandlungstisch zu zwingen. Wir haben auch festgestellt, dass es
verschiedene Optionen gibt, die die Ukrainer nutzen können,
wenn sie tatsächlich
zuerst ihre Offensive beginnen, auch Täuschungsversuche
Um die Russen zu zwingen, Reserven
in den Nordosten des Landes zu bringen, könnte es
auch möglich sein, eine amphibische Landung im
Süden durchzuführen, die später
aufgrund der Zerstörung des Nova
Chakov-Staudamms und natürlich eines Angriffs
auf die Brücke über die
Kch-Straße nicht möglich war  Einige Dinge funktionierten, andere nicht, aber
schließlich begannen die Ukrainer am 4. Juni
ihren Angriff entlang
dreier Hauptangriffsachsen, eine
nördlich von Toak und Milito Pole, die
andere nördlich von Bans Maria Pole und die
dritte im Gebiet von
Bakut. Die Erwartungen waren hoch  Aus
der Offensive ging man davon aus, dass
vor allem die Ausrüstung, die
aus dem Westen geliefert wurde, also moderne
Kampfpanzer wie der Leopard oder der
Challenger oder Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge
wie der CV90 oder de Bradley oder de M,
den
Unterschied machen werden, aber die ersten Stunden zeigen das
Die russische Verteidigungslinie war gut
vorbereitet und das waren die Bilder, die wir
tatsächlich zu Beginn der
ukrainischen Operation sahen, und es war General
Salushi, der Kommandeur der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte, der die Operationen praktisch stoppte,
weil die
Verluste so hoch waren  Ich möchte
Ihnen unser kurzes Video der 47.
mechanisierten Brigade zeigen, die
den Angriff
nördlich von Tokmak und Milito anführte, um Ihnen
eine Vorstellung davon zu geben, wie die Situation aussah,
als die Ukrainer versuchten,
in die russische Verteidigung einzudringen
[  Musik]
[Musik]
Zeilen Nachdem wir uns
das Video angesehen haben, möchten wir
Ihnen nun eine Vorstellung davon geben, wie eine so
komplexe Operation aussehen kann.
Deshalb verwenden wir ein Handbuch der US-
Armee und dieses Handbuch beschreibt detailliert,
welche Art von Fähigkeiten Sie benötigen  Wenn
Sie eine erfolgreiche Durchbruchsoperation durchführen möchten,
um
zu einer feindlichen Verteidigungslinie durchzubrechen,
sind bestimmte Begriffe
wichtig. Der erste Begriff ist der Begriff „
Unterdrücken“. Daher ist es wichtig, dass Sie über
Schutzkräfte verfügen, die die
feindlichen Streitkräfte reduzieren  Auf der anderen Seite hat dies jedoch
nicht ganz gut funktioniert. Der nächste
wichtige Begriff ist der Begriff „
undurchsichtig“. Sie müssen also Ihre Kräfte
vor dem Feind verbergen, indem Sie beispielsweise Rauch
oder Rauchgranaten verwenden. Hier wurde Rauch verwendet,
aber nur 3 %  Von allen Feuereinsätzen
der ukrainischen Seite wurde tatsächlich
Rauch abgefeuert. Der nächste Begriff ist der Begriff „sicher“.
Sie müssen den Bereich isolieren, in dem Sie
den Durchbruch durchführen möchten, und Sie
müssen sicherstellen, dass der Feind ihn
nicht nutzen kann  Seine mobilen Reserven
gegen Sie haben auch nur in einigen wenigen
Fällen funktioniert, weil die Russen
bestimmte Mittel aus der Ferne eingesetzt haben,
wie Hubschrauber, aber vor allem mobile
Panzerabwehrteams, die gegen
die ukrainischen Truppen arbeiteten, und der letzte Begriff,
der wichtig ist, ist der Begriff  Reduzieren Sie,
weil Sie
alle Hindernisse auf der anderen Seite
wie die Minenfelder, die
Panzergräben und
natürlich den Drachen Tas und alle anderen
Hindernisse erobern und überwinden müssen, um in die
russische Verteidigung einzudringen  Tatsache ist,
dass man nicht angreifen kann, wenn man nicht alle diese vier
Fähigkeiten erfüllt,
und genau das ist
zu Beginn der
Ukan-Offensive passiert. Es sind drei bestimmte
Abschnitte entlang der Front
Lassen Sie uns noch einmal einen etwas
detaillierteren Blick auf all die unterschiedlichen
Fähigkeiten werfen, die beide Seiten hatten. Fangen wir
zuerst mit der russischen Seite an, also
hatten die Russen eine Vielzahl unterschiedlicher
Ressourcen, die sie tatsächlich nutzten.
Minenfelder, Drachentees, Concertino-Draht,
mobile Anti-Anti-  Panzer- und Truppentruppen, lokale
Feuerunterstützung wie Mörser, aber auch
mobile Reserven wie schwere mechanisierte
Einheiten, die in Bereitschaft standen und
gegen die ukrainische Seite eingesetzt wurden, aber am
wichtigsten war, dass sie über erhebliche Konkurrenzunterstützung verfügten,
insbesondere Artillerie und
Raketenartillerie und natürlich den Luftbereich,
weil sie eingesetzt wurden  Ihre
Hubschrauber aus sicherer Entfernung und
Bodenangriffsflugzeuge und sie verfügten über
ausreichend Drohnen, die sie
zur Aufklärung und natürlich auch
als Cicat eingesetzt wurden. Die Drohnen gegen die
ukrainischen Truppen auf der anderen Seite
waren die Ukrainer auch bereit,
diese Durchbruchsoperation durchzuführen
Natürlich verfügten sie über Elemente, mit denen sie
die feindlichen Hindernisse verringern konnten. Sie verfügten über eine
durchbrechende Streitmacht, bestehend aus
Hauptpedalpanzern und Infanterie-Kampffahrzeugen, und
sie hatten auch Kompatibilitätsunterstützung wie
Artillerie und auch Raketenartillerie, aber
die Luftkomponente fehlte völlig,
also gab es keine
Kampfhubschrauber, keine Kampfflugzeuge und
natürlich gab es auch
keine speziellen Waffensysteme wie Boden-
Boden-Raketen wie Attam, die nicht
rechtzeitig abgefeuert wurden, und natürlich war die
Anzahl der Drohnen, die sie einsetzen konnten,
deutlich geringer als auf russischer
Seite  war, dass es
taktische Erfolge gab, wie zum Beispiel, dass es den Ukrainern
gelang,
bestimmte Stützpunkte entlang der
Verteidigungslinien wie Raputin und BBO zu besetzen, aber sie
waren nicht in der Lage, in die Verteidigungslinien einzudringen
oder Richtung
Süden zu durchbrechen, und wenn man die Ergebnisse vergleicht  In
einem größeren Maßstab können wir sehen, dass es
nördlich von Tokmak und Milito
nur einen Bruch von etwa 8 bis 10 Kilometern gab.
Östlich davon, nördlich von Bans und
Marapole, war die Brücke etwa 12 Kilometer lang
und auch in Bakut waren die Ergebnisse sehr gut
Moderat und verglichen mit der Entfernung
vom Durchbruchgebiet zum Meeresspiegel
kann man tatsächlich sehen, dass die Ergebnisse
im Vergleich zum beabsichtigten
operativen Ergebnis und dem strategischen
Effekt, der von
ukrainischer Seite geplant war, sehr gering ausfielen, wenn wir die
Verteidigungslinie betrachten  Aus dem russischen SES
können wir dann ersehen, dass es sich um ein sehr komplexes
System verschiedener Verteidigungslinien handelte, also
gab es eine konkurrierende Außenpostenlinie, die
natürlich von den Ukrainern durchbrochen wurde,
es gab eine Verteidigungslinie, die sogar
von einer zweiten Verteidigungslinie in der Tiefe unterstützt wurde
Es gab weitere Verteidigungslinien
südlich von Raboia und sogar die
Verteidigungslinie um die Haupthauptstädte herum, so
dass es den Ukrainern gelang,
die Kampflinie des Außenpostens zu durchbrechen und
in die erste Verteidigungslinie einzudringen, aber
der Angriff wurde schließlich in diesem
Gebiet gestoppt  Die Frage ist, was
mit den ukrainischen Game-Changern passiert ist. Wir haben
die Rolle der
mechanisierten Streitkräfte bereits besprochen, aber wir sollten nicht
vergessen, dass signifikante andere
Waffensysteme nicht verfügbar waren, entweder
weil sie nicht geliefert wurden oder weil die
Menge gering war, so dass die Boden-Lun einen kleinen
Durchmesser hatte  Bombe war nicht verfügbar, sie ist
immer noch nicht verfügbar, sie könnte
nächstes Jahr geliefert werden. Auf der anderen Seite wurde
die Su
24m natürlich für den Einsatz von Storm
Shadow auf Sculp angepasst, aber es ist kein Problem
der Menge dieses Luft-Boden-
Waffensystems, das es ist  Frage nach der
Anzahl der verfügbaren Plattformen wie
der Su 24m, die gegen die
russische Seite eingesetzt werden könnten, und der dritte sehr
wichtige Aspekt war, dass die sogenannten
Brigaden der Offensive die neun
Brigaden waren, die mehr oder weniger
vom Westen vorbereitet wurden, plus die drei
Brigaden, die von den
Ukrainern vorbereitet wurden, hatten offensichtlich nicht den richtigen
Ausbildungsstatus, um diese sehr
komplexe
Aufgabe zu erfüllen. Ich bezog mich bereits auf einen
Artikel in der Washington Post. In dem
Artikel in der Washington Post wurden
die Probleme insbesondere in der
Formierungsphase der Brigade ausführlich dargelegt  Daher
gab es einen unterschiedlichen Ansatz für die
Durchführung der Operation, insbesondere von
der US-Seite und von der ukrainischen Seite,
während die US-Seite betonte, dass es
eine Hauptanstrengung geben sollte, also eine
Angriffsrichtung auf die Stadt Tokmak
und Milito der Ukrainer  bestand darauf,
tatsächlich drei AES-Angriffe zu verfolgen, also einen
in Richtung Mille, den anderen in
Richtung Bans und Maria Pole und den
dritten Angriff entlang BMOT, sodass die
russische Seite den Vorteil hatte, dass sie
mehr oder weniger gegen
ukrainische Truppen kämpfen konnte  Drei verschiedene
Teile der Frontlinie, und das
ist das Argument der USA, machten es für
die Ukrainer schwierig, durchzubrechen, weil
sie nicht wirklich alle
Truppen an einem bestimmten Punkt zur Verfügung hatten
und äh, um tatsächlich die Kraft zu haben,
tatsächlich durchzubrechen  Richtung
Süden, nachdem die Anfangsphase der
ukrainischen Offensive gescheitert war, befahl General Solu, die
Taktik zu ändern, so dass
die Ukrainer zu Beginn der Offensive
versuchten,
von einem Feld auf das andere anzugreifen, und wenn man das mit einem Schachsprung vergleicht,
waren sie
gefangen  in einer Mischung aus russischen
Panzerabwehrwaffen, russischen Hubschraubern, Minenfeldern
und anderen Anlagen. Was sie also
tatsächlich getan haben, ist, dass sie die Taktik auf eine
andere Art und Weise geändert haben, und deshalb müssen wir
ein wenig das Gelände in der
Ukraine verstehen, das sehr, sehr flach ist und das
Verschiedene Geländemerkmale sind
durch Baumgrenzen getrennt, daher bestand die Idee der
Rans nicht darin, von einem Feld zum
anderen anzugreifen, sondern diesen
Baumgrenzen zwischen den Feldern zu folgen und
von einem Feld zum anderen anzugreifen, und das
brachte Erfolg  In sehr, sehr langsamer
Bewegung und mit hohen
Verlusten. Nachdem wir uns die
taktischen und operativen Herausforderungen angesehen haben,
müssen wir auch einen Blick auf das
strategische Ergebnis der Offensive werfen, und
diese Karte zeigt sehr deutlich, wie der
Erfolg aus Großbritannien heraus war
Sehen Sie tatsächlich, dass entlang der drei
Hauptangriffsachsen, also nördlich von Tokmak und Mito
Pole, nördlich von Banson Maria Pole und im
Gebiet von Bakut, der Erfolg sehr
begrenzt war, also 8 bis 10 Kilometer im zentralen
Bereich oder 10 bis 12 Kilometer und sehr
begrenzte Ergebnisse  In der Gegend von Bakut auf
der anderen Seite hatten die Russen ebenfalls
Erfolg, weil sie auch
bestimmte Teile entlang der Frontlinie besetzten, aber
das Problem besteht darin, dass die Brigaden der
Offensive die neun Brigaden, die
vom Westen ausgerüstet wurden, und die drei
Brigaden, die vom Westen ausgerüstet wurden  Diese von der
Ukraine ausgerüsteten Brigaden der Offensive
sind inzwischen abgenutzt, so dass sie nicht
mehr verfügbar sind, und sie sind
entlang der gesamten Frontlinie aufgeteilt, wie die
Mech-
Brigade der 47er-Jahre, die
am 4. Juni den Angriff mit dem Speer traf und es nun
tatsächlich war  aus dem
zentralen Bereich in die FA verlegt, weil
dort der Druck auf die ukrainischen Truppen sehr groß ist.
Auch hier müssen wir in die
Vergangenheit blicken, um eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen, wie eine erfolgreiche
Operation tatsächlich aussehen kann, und
es gibt ein Beispiel, das ein sehr
gutes Beispiel dafür ist  Es zeigt, wie
wichtig die verschiedenen
Teilstreitkräfte sind, und dies ist das Beispiel
der Operation Cobra im Sommer 1944 in der
Normandie, bei der es um den Ausbruch
der Teilstreitkräfte von den Brückenköpfen
entlang der langen Strände und den Vorstoß
in die Tiefen der Normandie ging  Die französische
Landschaft und der Beginn von Cobra
waren die Anfangsphase einer massiven
Bombardierung der deutschen Stellungen
entlang der Vorwärtslinie der eigenen
Truppen, und die massive
Bombardierung der Alliierten führte zu hohen Verlusten der
deutschen Streitkräfte, in diesem Fall der
Panala-Divis-Division, die größer war
entlang der Vorwärtslinie waren weniger
eigene Truppen stationiert, und die Amerikaner konnten
mit drei
Panzerdivisionen nach Süden und
Südwesten durchbrechen, sodass wir tatsächlich sehen können, dass
der Unterschied insbesondere durch
dieses Bombardement zu Beginn der
Offensive und jene gemacht wurde  Luftressourcen, über die die
Ukrainer zu
Beginn ihrer Offensive
Anfang Juni dieses
Jahres nicht verfügten, während von Woche zu Woche
immer deutlicher wurde, dass es
auf der anderen Seite des
Hügels keinen wirklichen ukrainischen Erfolg oder Durchbruch geben wird  Die Moral der russischen Seite stieg und
auch hier können wir sehen, dass die Russen
in ihrer Propaganda Elemente aus
dem sogenannten Großen Vaterländischen Krieg im
Zweiten Weltkrieg verwenden, wo der sowjetische
Soldat erfolgreich gegen den deutschen
Tigerpanzer kämpfte, wie heute, wo der russische
Soldat kämpfte  erfolgreich den deutschen
Leopard-Panzer oder den amerikanischen
Bradley und das bringt mich auf den Punkt,
denn das Narrativ bis jetzt war, dass
der russische Soldat nicht in der Lage ist,
gleichberechtigt auf der ukrainischen Seite zu kämpfen, und
das ist ein Narrativ, das wir neu definieren müssen,
weil Sie der größte Fehler sind  Was man tun kann,
ist eigentlich, den Feind zu unterschätzen,
und ich gebe Ihnen hier ein weiteres Beispiel vom
Militärgeheimdienst aus Großbritannien,
weil die Briten hier
tatsächlich zugeben, dass insbesondere die russische
Luftverteidigung nicht nur
gegen die ukrainische Luftwaffe, sondern auch
gegen bestimmte Luftstreitkräfte recht erfolgreich ist  Boden- oder Boden-
Boden-Systeme wie die Himas- und die
GMLRS-Rakete oder natürlich die Scalp- und
Storm-Shadow-Raketen, die in einem
bestimmten Maßstab von der
russischen Seite abgeschossen werden, und die Russen
passen sich auf sehr einfache und sehr
erfolgreiche Weise an  Zum Beispiel verwenden sie
alte Bomben mit
einem Gewicht von etwa 500 bis 1.000 oder sogar
1.500 kg, die sie anpassen, und aus einer
Müllbombe können sie
eine Aufklärungsbombe erkennen, die sie
tatsächlich aus sicherer Entfernung
gegen die Ukrainer einsetzen können  Wie Sie
hier auf diesem Bild tatsächlich sehen können,
wo Su 34 vier dieser UMPK-
Bomben abfeuerte, und natürlich sind es nicht nur diese
Bomben, die den Ukrainern schweren Schaden zufügen,
sondern es ist insbesondere
auch das Arsenal der Russen, wenn es
um Marschflugkörper und Marschflugkörper geht  Ballistische
Raketen, denn auch hier müssen wir
zugeben, dass die Produktionsrate des
russischen Standorts erheblich gestiegen ist,
und um Ihnen eine Vorstellung
von den Ergebnissen dieser Angriffe zu geben, möchten wir
Ihnen ein Video zeigen, in dem Sie
die Auswirkungen dieser Angriffe tatsächlich sehen können  Ump-
Schlüsselbomben gegen Aufmarschgebiete der
ukrainischen
[Musik] [
Musik]
-Seite [
Musik],
während die ukrainische Seite
dringend bestimmte Waffensysteme benötigt
und nach mehreren Monaten und als
klar war, dass der ukrainische Erfolg nicht
wirklich so war wie beabsichtigt  Die Amerikaner
lieferten ein bestimmtes Waffensystem, um
den Ukrainern die Möglichkeit zu geben,
in die Offensive zu gehen und
wieder Schwung zu bekommen, und dieses Waffensystem
war die taktische Rakete der Armee, die
in einer Menge zwischen 20 und
30 Stück an die Ukrainer geliefert wurde und
natürlich  Die Ukrainer brauchten diese
Waffensysteme, um gegen bestimmte
Kräfte der russischen Seite zu kämpfen, und einer
dieser bestimmten Kräfte waren natürlich die
russischen Hubschrauber, also
wurden diese Angriffslager gegen einen russischen
Flugplatz mit einer Ansammlung von Sprengköpfen eingesetzt, und
man konnte sofort sehen, was  Es hat
einen gewissen Unterschied gemacht, wenn
Waffensysteme zur Verfügung stehen, die auf
der ukrainischen Seite benötigt werden, denn auf der russischen Seite
wurden mehrere Hubschrauber nicht einmal zerstört, sondern
sogar beschädigt,
und diese taktischen und operativen
Beurteilungen bringen uns zu dem Punkt, an dem
wir angekommen sind  Eine Pattsituation im Konflikt
und eine allgemeine Lösung. Der Befehlshaber
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte hat erst kürzlich
in einem Artikel sehr klar zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass
es keinen solch tiefgreifenden und
schönen Durchbruch gibt. Es gibt
tatsächlich eine Pattsituation und eines der
Dinge, die dahinterstecken  Stall Mate
ist
die Situation, in der beide Seiten
tatsächlich beobachten können, was die andere Seite
tut. Warum ist das möglich, weil es
ein sogenanntes transparentes
Schlachtfeld gibt, weil Hunderte von Drohnen
jede Seite beobachten können, sodass man
tatsächlich sehen kann, um welche Seite es sich handelt?
Bereitstellungskräfte und welche Seite von der
Bereitstellung in das Manöver übergeht, da diese
Drohnen diese Aktionen nicht nur beobachten können,
sondern auch gegen
diese Bereitstellungsbereiche oder gegen die
Manövertruppe eingesetzt werden und es einen bestimmten
Waffentyp gibt, der sehr erfolgreich
eingesetzt wird  Beide Seiten und dies ist die
sogenannte First-Person-Vrone, die
für Sie ein sehr einfacher und kostengünstiger Vorteil ist, um sie
gegen schweres Gerät
wie einen Leoparden oder einen Challenger-Panzer einzusetzen. Diese
First-Person-VI-Drohnen werden von beiden
Seiten eingesetzt, so auch die Ukrainer  Das Problem besteht darin, dass
die Russen diese Drohnen
tatsächlich im
industriellen Maßstab produzieren können, wie wir hier sehen können, und
im nächsten Video möchten wir Ihnen zeigen,
wie es aussieht, wenn einer dieser Drohnen zum
ersten Mal eingesetzt wird  Die Person, die Sie mit Drohnen
steuern, greift in diesem Fall tatsächlich einen schweren Hauptpanzer an,
ein
[Musik]
-Leard,
aber es ist nicht nur die Produktion
dieser First-View-Drohnen, die einen
Unterschied macht, es ist auch so, dass der
militärisch-industrielle Komplex der
Russen dazu in der Lage ist  Wir produzieren ein sehr
leistungsfähiges Waffensystem wie die sogenannte
Lanset-Kamiki-Drohne, weil diese Drohne
den Russen die Möglichkeit gibt,
tief hinter der ukrainischen Front zu agieren.
Sie verwenden tatsächlich ein System von
Jäger-Killer-Drohnen, also gibt es Jäger-
Drohnen, die die Aufklärung übernehmen, und
Killer-Drohnen  Wie die Lanet, die tief hinter dem Schlachtfeld
an bestimmten Anlagen der Ukrainer arbeiten,
möchten wir Ihnen ein Beispiel geben,
das zeigt, wie schwierig die Situation für
die ukrainische Seite ist, denn in diesem
Video können Sie tatsächlich den Einsatz einer
LAN-Drohne sehen  Gegen zwei hochwertige Vermögenswerte
ist eines ein SU2-Five-UH-Bodenangriffsflugzeug
und das andere ein
MIG29-Kampfflugzeug.
[Musik]
Als allgemeine Lösung wird also gesagt, dass der Krieg
ins Stocken geraten ist und das bedeutet, dass
der Krieg weitergeht, also lassen Sie uns jetzt  Schauen Sie sich
die Frontlinie bei diesem 1.200 Kilometer langen Kilometer an und
schauen wir uns entlang der Frontlinie
in bestimmten Abschnitten im Detail an, was
dort vor sich geht, damit wir zunächst einmal beurteilen können,
dass die Russen wie im letzten Weltkrieg
versuchen, die Ukrainer
zum Einsatz zu zwingen  Sie versuchen auch, ihre taktischen und operativen
Reserven entlang der gesamten Frontlinie zu
nutzen oder bereits die
strategischen Reserven der Ukraine zu verbrauchen, weil die
Ukrainer versuchen, neue
Brigaden vorzubereiten, um die
Möglichkeit für eine neue Offensive im
Frühjahr oder Sommer nächsten Jahres zu haben, also lassen Sie uns das tun
Beginnend im Nordosten der Frontlinie
im Gebiet von Kopan V können wir
zunehmende russische Angriffe beobachten, um
die Ukrainer von der Frontlinie aus
Richtung Westen hinter den So-Cal-Oscar-
Fluss zu drängen. Im Gebiet von Bakut
verloren die Ukrainer ihr gesamtes Gelände
Zu Beginn der Offensive gewannen die Russen
nördlich von Pmut bei Crovo und südlich
bei
Geva. Südlich davon
erlitten die Russen hohe Verluste. Die Russen
versuchten bereits mehrmals,
die AFA einzukreisen, aber die schweren Verluste wurden ihnen
zugefügt  Von der ukrainischen Seite auf der
russischen Seite gelang es den Russen dennoch, einen
Großteil der Marinka zu erobern,
und natürlich verstärkten sie auch ihre
Angriffe entlang des Ugar-Uros-Teils der
Frontlinie und in Norina, einem
der Hauptangriffsziele der
Ukrainer, die die Russen waren  Sie waren
nicht einmal in der Lage, die Frontlinie zu stabilisieren,
aber sie konnten
mindestens ein paar hundert
Meter nach Westen vordringen, und im Süden
ist die Situation in Rapia ein wenig ähnlich,
auch die Russen konnten
die Front stabilisieren  Linie und ging in den
Angriff und besetzte bestimmtes Gelände,
das zuvor tatsächlich
von der ukrainischen Seite besetzt oder befreit wurde. Die
Erfolgsgeschichte der Ukrainer
ist derzeit immer noch die Brücke bei Green
Key, auf der die Ukrainer mit
amphibischen Angriffskräften zu
landen versuchen  Auf der anderen Seite des Flusses
besteht die Hauptaufgabe dieser Operation
vor allem darin, im Informationsbereich zu zeigen,
dass
auf der Ukan-Seite noch Schwung vorhanden ist, und natürlich
die Russen zu zwingen, ihre taktischen und
operativen Reserven einzusetzen, um
zumindest zu blockieren  Die ukrainischen Streitkräfte in diesem
Gebiet waren bis heute ein echter Erfolg. Die Ukrainer hatten
im Schwarzen Meer bis heute, weil
die Ukrainer in der Lage waren,
die russischen Seestreitkräfte
von der Westrichtung in die Mitte oder
sogar in den Osten zu zwingen. Sie waren erfolgreich,
weil sie sie nutzten  Eine Kombination aus UNM
Maritime-Systemen gegen die Schiffe
des Schwarzen Meeres, aber auch der Suu 24m und
den Scalp- und Storm Shadow AOG-
Bodenraketen, die zu einem
erheblichen Verlust an russischen Schiffen und
sogar zu einem U-Boot führte, das von
der ukrainischen
Seite auf der Insel zerstört wurde  Auf strategischer Ebene müssen wir noch
einmal bedenken, dass der nächste Winter
für die ukrainische Seite sehr schwierig sein wird,
weil die Russen, und das ist es,
was wir erwarten,
ihre Angriffe auf die kritische
Infrastruktur noch einmal verstärken. Im letzten Winter
gab es bereits verheerende Folgen  Bei
russischen Angriffen auf die kritische
Infrastruktur der Ukraine sagen
ukrainische Beamte, dass zwischen 50 und
60 % der kritischen
Infrastruktur der Ukraine zerstört wurden, die
Ukrainer konnten etwa 10 bis
15 % reparieren, aber jetzt ist es fraglich, ob die
Ukrainer in der Lage sein werden, den Rest zu sichern
50 % im Laufe des nächsten Winters,
insbesondere wenn wir sehen, dass die Russen
wieder damit begonnen haben, ihre Shahed-Drohnen in
der alten Version und sogar in einer modernen
Version einzusetzen, die recht schneller ist, was
es für die ukrainische Luftverteidigung ziemlich schwierig macht,
gegen sie zu kämpfen,
und natürlich wann  Wir schauen uns auch
die verschiedenen Marschflugkörper und
Raketen an, die sie tatsächlich einsetzen, und dabei
sollten wir nicht vergessen, dass es
in der Ukraine jeden Tag eine hohe Angriffsdichte gibt,
denn auf dieser Karte
können wir zum Beispiel von September bis November
die verschiedenen Flugspuren sehen  Vermögenswerte von
russischer Seite werden gegen die Ukrainer eingesetzt
und auch hier, wenn wir uns nur die
Shahid-Angriffe ansehen, dann können Sie sehen, dass die
Russen in den Tiefen des
Landes sind, weil sie tatsächlich
glauben, dass sich dort die wichtigsten Versorgungslager der
Ukrainer befinden und  Natürlich
sind sie auch auf der Jagd nach der sehr
wertvollen Su 24M, die die Ukrainer
als Trägerplattform für die Storm
Shadow- und Scout-Raketen nutzen. Vergessen wir nicht,
dass der Schwerpunkt der
Ukrainer auf dem Widerstand des Westens liegt,
und hier können wir das tun  Bei der theistischen Hilfe ist ein deutlicher Rückgang zu verzeichnen,
so dass in
den letzten Monaten nur ein geringer
Betrag an Hilfe
in den Westen gelangte. Dies ist besonders
bedeutsam, wenn wir uns die amerikanische
Seite ansehen, denn es sind vor allem die
Amerikaner, die den Unterschied machen  Und
die Ukrainer brauchen immer noch schwere Waffen
wie Panzer, Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge,
Artilleriegeschütze, wenn sie
nächstes Jahr wieder in die Offensive gehen wollen, und dabei ist
nicht nur die Lieferung der Systeme
wichtig, sondern auch die
Frage, wie viele Soldaten noch
verfügbar sind  Und wie viele Soldaten
kann die Ukraine für die Verteidigung
ihres Landes mobilisieren, um
vielleicht nächstes Jahr wieder in die Offensive zu gehen?
Damit komme ich zum letzten
Bild und ich möchte noch einmal
den ukrainischen Präsidenten
Selinski zitieren, der gesagt hat:  Wir
ziehen uns natürlich nicht zurück, es gab nicht diese
Art von tiefgreifender und schöner Offensive,
wie General Solution sagte, aber zumindest
ziehen wir nicht zurück und behalten
das Terrain, und natürlich ist es der Wille
des ukrainischen Volkes, weiter dagegen zu kämpfen
Russische Truppen in der
Ukraine, womit mein Kurzbericht endet. Ich möchte
mich ganz herzlich für Ihr
Zuhören bedanken und mich
bis zum nächsten
Mal verabschieden